One good representative of distributed version control systems, is
GIT. A distributed version control system that was initially designed
and developed by Linus Torvalds. I'm pretty sure you
know who Linus Torvalds is. He's basically this guy who
started and created the Linux operating system. And Linus
was unhappy with the existing version control systems, and wanted
a different one. He wanted to use it for maintaining
the Linux kernel. In particular, he wanted one with some
key characteristics. For example, the fact that it was distributed. He
wanted it to be fast. He wanted it to have a
simple design. And he wanted to have a strong support for
parallel branches, because many people were contributing to the kernel at the
same time. And therefore there many different branches of development. And
finally, he wanted for the virtual control system to be able to
handle large projects. As the Linux kernel is, and to do
it in an efficient way. So if you want to get an idea
of how popular GIT is today, there was a survey performed across the
Eclipse IDE users, and it showed that in 2013 GIT was used by
about 30% of the developers. So the, it had a 30% adoption rate.
So we will use a GIT as a version control system for the class.